jeudi dans le quartier des valendons la
victime un homme de 30 ans et percuté
dans sa voiture par un autre véhicule
il sort armé d'une batte de base-ball
frappe le premier véhicule et est abattu
de deux balles sur la voie publique
le tireur et son passager prennent la
fuite la voiture volée la veille équipée
de fausses plaques et retrouvé un peu
plus tard accidenté dans la vallée de
l'ouche dans le week-end qui suit le
passager de la voiture 19 ans une autre
personne 30 ans suspecté d'avoir apporté
son aide et enfin le tireur présumé un
dijonnais de 20 ans se sont tous
constitués prisonniers à ce stade de
l'enquêté
une piste de mobiles possibles a été
avancée par le procureur le meurtre
s'inscrit dans un contexte de règlements
de comptes sans pouvoir être plus précis
entre les trois auteurs présumés et la
famille de la victime un des règlements
de compte qui se déroulait depuis
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
avec des dégradations de véhicules des
incendies de véhicules
les chefs de mise en examen sont le
meurtre avec bande organisée dont que la
peine encourue est la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
pour l'instant donc la prémiditation en
l'état actuel des éléments n'a pas été
retenu le procureur ne dira pas quelle
peut être la toile de fond de ce
règlement de comptes
un placement sous mandat de dépôt des
trois personnes mises en examen a été
demandé par le parking